the ability to think long term and not
for the quick buck how do you grapple
with that what's your advice for young
people out there these days because
there's a lot of easy money out there
especially for women right now it's not
easy i mean i'm not gonna there is no
way of doing it that's look
here's the craziest thing about life
here's the craziest thing about life
we're all being tested the entire time
let me tell you man this is a one big
ass experiment of what you're really all
about and you're gonna fall many times
and you're gonna learn a lot about
yourself
and your goal is to keep trying to make
better choices it's not easy so i can't
sit there and play you know hey let me
tell you judge you know i'm not gonna be
doing that's your choice and everyone's
in different types of situations i just
will tell you
you know it's it's it's it's very like
even right now yesterday we're talking
about politics i said do you realize the
right candidate
with the right policies that we need in
america today would never get elected
let me say that one more time the right
candidate with the right policies
that america desperately needs today
would never win an election today why
because the right policies would be
folks
guess what
if you vote for me
we're cutting back on 50 percent of
entitlement programs
we're cutting back on unemployment
checks we're going to go from 6 months
to 90 days to 30 days
we're cutting back on all the spending
that we're doing we're cutting back on
the military spending that we're doing
we're going to put in more in cyber and
bio warfare and being prepared for that
because right now wars are not going to
be done up there it's going to be more
cyber what russia is doing what we're
going to
you're going to have to get to work the
next 8 12 years because we all have a
job to do
no one would vote for you even though
those are the right policies nobody
would vote for you right okay so
how many presidents become presidents
and they make policies that benefit you
30 years from now nobody nobody does
that everybody becomes a president just
like a the difference between a founder
and a ceo a founder started that company
it's emotional the ceo is just trying to
get the quarterly numbers to be hit so
it looks it's a very different mindset a
lot of today's presidents are just
trying to hit their quarterly numbers
that's all they're thinking about so
going back to your question on what
you're saying
how you tie these two together
man
life is a test of making short term
decisions versus long term and it ain't
easy bro when i think a lot of it too
because you have to be comfortable with
your decisions and if you're comfortable
doing only fans or whatever pornography
i think i do it's your body your choice
that's the way i look at it but what we
come back to people when they uh they
they take control of your life and i
look back at decisions that i made that
didn't i didn't know what the third and
fourth order effects were going to be
but i got proposed a lot of
decent deals back in the day when i
started youtube it was multi-channel
networks it's when those were really
popular they were taking essentially 12
digital creators putting them under one
marketing umbrella cross-pollinating
audiences and getting brand deals and
then pushing them through each different
person and i took a look at it and some
it was like hyper hyper like i could
have made a lot of money advantageous
for me and then some of the other stuff
that i started to see was
all of a sudden the parent company kind
of started to tell these guys what they
can and can't do and i'm an irreverent
guy that likes firearms and i knew that
would always be an implication with
working with these other people and so i
never did it i said screw it you know
what my business partner at the time
jared taylor said hey let's let's start
some shirts and all we did was go i'm
going to put a design in the shirt that
i want to wear every day and a really
comfy t-shirt that it feels good and we
went with what we wanted how we wanted
to do it and it took longer but the
consequence of those decisions were now
when i'm 35 years old i i own my ideas
and the biggest the worst decision i
ever could have made in business was
allowing someone else to own my
intellectual property because i know
that's what i am i'm a visionary i'm a
really creative guy i'm not the best in
operations but guess you can hire those
people in and all that so
it kind of goes back to when you're
talking about the one through ten
analogy
is focusing on your core competencies
i'm like i i'm a creator i'm a visionary
and i wanna own that and i never let
anybody else own me and that's i think
what is a testament to my success i kind
of unknowingly did that but then i
started to realize it more and more as
my life went on yeah
power and respect to you guys man much
respect to you guys for what you did and
to be where you're at right now you guys
are just getting started i mean right
now uh uh 10 000 veterans that means if
you got 10 000 veterans working for you
got 20 000 employees you guys are on
track to get there uh it's a great
success story in america and you guys
are not slowing down do you know to to
answer your question for you so for me
you know i'm all about finding ways to
drive you or me better right it's like
how do you because when you run a sales
organization with you know
27 000 insurance agents you have to
learn this person is going to be driven
in a different way than different this
person than this person than me than you
we're all different right okay
do you know what is the highest driver
you know the highest driver
the highest driver my experience has
been purely pride
pride in what
pride in your last name
okay which is passed down from your
parents
pride in your nationality your heritage
you have to have pride in that that's
your blood you have me whatever people
say you still have to have pride in that
pride in your industry what you do as a
trade you have to have a lot of pride in
your trade whatever i don't care what
you do you got to have pride in your
trade and constantly get better pride in
your community
pride in your family pride in your
country
you can everything is about
representation
this there's only one of this in the
world okay and that's you
how you represent yourself to the world
eventually one day they're going to sit
there and say
i tell you man i'm just this mad guy man
who's a freaking badass look
you know respect salute this adam guy
the way he lived his life now you know a
lot of times at the beginning but i got
to tell you man this guy's salute
that is worth making the long-term
decisions because all this short-term
stuff that we do
it's going to come it's going to go by
but it's going to stick around with you
for a very
very long time anybody can take the
short-term victories it ain't hard to do
only a few can take the long-term
victories and i'm telling you right now
history favors those who take the
long-term victories but it's just going
to take 20 to 40 years for people to
realize who the real players in the game
were not two years not five years not 10
years adam 20 to 40 years so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]